[Music]
ever since Netflix dropped the trailer
for to all the boys I've loved before we
have been obsessed we don't know how
different or similar it would be to
Ginni Hans best-selling novel so we
can't stop trying to figure out
everything about this movie stay tuned
for the biggest craziest theory we could
find
do you love all these awesome teen
rom-coms that Netflix keeps producing
then subscribe to the things to stay
up-to-date on all the teen movie and
television hits and now it's time for
five crazy theories about the new
Netflix original to all the boys I've
loved before on August 17th 2018 Netflix
will release a new teen romance a comedy
called to all the boys I've loved before
the trailer dropped at the end of July
2018 and we just can't stop watching it
if you haven't read the book consider
this your spoiler alerts the movie stars
Alana Condor as Lara Jean song Kofi
she's a quiet girl with secret loves who
lives with her dad and two sisters she
keeps a tio box in her closet with love
letters she writes to all the boys she
has ever loved one day the letters
mysteriously get sent out to all the
boys and they all confront her can you
imagine what a nightmare that would be
her current love josh is currently the
boyfriend of her older sister Margot can
you say complicated one of the other
guys super popular Peter who Laura Jean
no longer loves confronts her on the
track at school he just broke up with
Genevieve and wants a clean break Peter
has the idea to pretend to date Laura
Jean so Josh won't be suspicious and her
sister won't be hurt what an amazing guy
so these two fake date and become really
close they are total relationship goals
and aren't even really together but
there's a whole bunch of drama and
comedy mixed with a ton of fun that is
guaranteed to make this movie the next
big hit to all the boys I've loved
before is based on a book of the same
name by Jenny Han the Arthur loosely
based the book on herself because she
used to write long love letters to her
crushes the book was released in April
2014 and it was a huge success it spent
40 whole weeks on the New York's the
best time seller lists for young adult
fiction
with a book that awesome the movie just
has to be amazing and the cast is
absolutely perfect this movie has been
in the works for a long time it was
first set to be turned into a movie in
2014 filming finally began in the summer
of 2017 and Netflix bought the rights in
2018 so we've been waiting way too long
for this movie hurry up already we can
already tell there will be some
differences between the book and the
movie and that's pretty typical when
books are turned into movies some things
just don't work as well in films we are
super curious about all the changes that
will be made in the book the plan to
fake date Peter is Laura Gene's idea but
in the trailer
Peter suggests it that's at least one
major plot point that's changing so we
don't know everything that will happen
here are five theories about to all the
boys I've loved before Laura Jean ends
up with Peter in the book Peter was
Laura jeans first kiss way back in
eighth grade she wrote the love letter
to him in middle school but of course he
doesn't get it until junior year they
set up guidelines for fake dating but
it's got to be hard to pretend to date
someone without catching feelings for
them you go Laura Jean she's one tough
chick to pretend to date one guy while
loving another just so she won't hurt
anyone if Peter looks familiar it's
because Noah Centennial plays Jesus
adams-foster in the TV show the Fosters
they're going to be spending a lot of
time together in the book we know they
end up falling for each other but the
book ends with Laura Jean writing him a
love letter after a falling out there's
a good chance that after she declares
her love for Peter they actually end up
together in the movie would you be super
disappointed if they fell for each other
but didn't get together we think that
might cause a ton of outrage from fans
of the movie so are Peter and Laura Jean
the OTP or is it one of the other
recipients of her love letters we have
so many questions we definitely want to
know how they all confront Laura Jean
Laura Jean ends up with Josh okay this
would be a pretty big difference from
the way the book ends but stick with us
Laura Jean is totally head-over-heels
for Josh but josh is dating her sister
Margo upward in the book Margo breaks up
with Josh because she is planning to
move to
Scotland for college Josh admits his
first crush was actually Laura Jean
say what how did he end up with Margot
OMG
we hope this part ends up in the movie
when Lara Jean starts fake dating Peter
so she doesn't hurt Margot Josh gets
jealous they end up kissing but Laura
Jean decides she'd rather actually date
Peter so much drama and Margot gets
super upset when she finds out about the
kiss but did her love for Josh just
totally disappear can she really just
stop loving Josh after having feelings
for him for so long we think she
probably feels super conflicted here's
why they might end up together first
Laura genes feelings for Josh were
really strong those feelings don't just
disappear right and Josh did admit he
used to crush on Laura Jean that scene
from the book left us later on in the
book Josh totally tries to protect Laura
Jean during her confrontation with Peter
he sticks up for her and doesn't want
her getting hurt
he's basically a hero at this point so
what if Laura Jean besides she really
does love Josh more she's got a lot of
good reasons to end up with him but
would it be totally wrong to end up with
her sister's ex we sure hope sisterly
love Trump's all of this but we bet
there is some serious sister drama
happening the rumor is true okay every
rom-com needs a part where the main
character ends up heartbroken it's
basically a requirement in the book
Peter and Lauren Jean go on a school ski
trip where do we find this school we
want to go on a ski trip with all of our
besties that would be so fun on the trip
Peter tells Laura Jean he has real
feelings for her he confesses that fake
dating her is just not enough and he
wants to really date her oMG it's the
moment we've been waiting for Laura Jean
totally has feelings for him too
the two kiss in a hot tub but they are
seen by someone awkward enter Genevieve
and she is petit AF she tells Largey
that people are talking about the couple
they believe that Peter and Laura Jean
did a lot more than kiss if you know
what we mean then Genevieve says Peter
did not deny it Laura Jean is so hurt
and embarrassed and she totally avoids
Peter for the rest of the break that
would be so terrible if it happened to
someone in real
life gossip is so not cool you guys
there are some good reasons why the
rumor may actually be true in the movie
even though they only kiss in the book
first of all in the trailer we steal our
genes dad give her some protection if
you catch our meaning she is outraged
and mortified but could that scene be
foreshadowing for later in the movie
also if Peter really didn't deny it
maybe the rumor is true why I denied the
truth right
we don't blame our gene for being
totally upset though that sort of stuff
is no one else's business
either way Genevieve is trouble and
successfully drives the our gene
Peter apart we'll just have to see how
that resolves who sent the letters all
the drama in to all the boys I've loved
before starts when Laura jeans secret
love letters are mailed to the boys she
loved thousand mystery through most of
the book we can assume it will be a big
mystery in the movie too in the trailer
she says no one knows about the letters
that is total foreshadowing though
because someone had to mail them out in
the book we find out toward the ends
that Laura jeans little sister Kitty
sends the love letters she was mad
because Laura Jean almost revealed that
Kitty has a crush on Josh
wait a second Josh was dating their
older sister Margo does every song covey
sister have a thing for Josh he must be
one amazing guy we already know Kitty is
going to be different in the movie in
the book Kitty is only nine years old
but in the movie she's played by Anna
Cathcart who is 15 years old you may
know her as dizzy Tremaine from
dissonance 2 if they changed her age so
much did they change her role in Laurens
love life drama
another possibility is at Margot sins
the letters she and Laura Jean are close
but what did she discover that Laura
Jean had feelings for her boyfriends
maybe she sends the letters to get
revenge on Laura Jean it would certainly
be a way to humiliate her younger sister
speaking of Margot she is played by
Janel Parrish she's no stranger to teen
drama the last possibility is like Chris
symptom Chris played by Madeline Arthur
is Laura Dean's best friend and she is
way more outgoing than Laura Jean she's
always urging her to get out there more
and not be so afraid maybe she sent out
the letters to force Laura Jean to
confront her feelings
we sure hope she would be more
considerate of her friend's feelings
though who knows maybe there is someone
else he mails the letters who we are
just glad this didn't happen to us who
do you think sent the letters let us
know in the comments
there could be sequels we are
ridiculously excited about - all the
boys I've loved before we cannot wait
for the release on August 17th 2018 you
can find us piled up in front of Netflix
on the day it comes out the book is the
first of the series of three books the
second book is called PS I still love
you it focuses on Laura Jean and Peters
relationship there's some serious drama
from Genevieve again and Lara Jean feels
really suspicious that Peter is back
with his ex plus we get a lot more of
John Ambrose McLaren he is Laura jeans
former love from Model UN and Laura
jeans dad has a happy romantic storyline
to the third book is called always and
forever Laura Jean this is all about
Laura James senior year and trying to
get into a college near Peter we get all
the fields that come with leaving high
school and trying to have a
long-distance relationship and their dad
gets married which is awesome it's a
perfect end to the trilogy so will there
be two more movies on Netflix
Lana Condor who plays Laura Jean did a
Twitter Q&A about to all the boys I've
loved before a fan asked if there would
be sequels based on the other two books
Lana replied that she sure hope so and
it all depends on how successful the
first movie is she said we should all
definitely watch it a million times to
show the filmmakers we want more that
will be a problem Lana we already know
we are going to love this movie we
cannot wait to get all of our questions
answered about the new movie are you as
excited as we are about to all the boys
I've loved before let us know what you
are looking forward to the most in the
comments and that's it for five crazy
theories about to all the boys I've
loved before be sure to give this video
a big thumbs up if this is your first
time visiting don't forget to subscribe
for more awesome content
[Music]